good evening members and members of the
public and officers
I don't think we've got any press here
Charles welcome to the cabinet meeting
just uh some housekeeping uh if the fire
alarm is activated vacate the offices of
other stairs please do not use the lifts
score excuse me assemble in holy Square
on the green officers will assist you
and advise when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is Pro in
progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
the following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
items five six and seven councilor
Whitehead item seven councilor Duckworth
and councilor Yates does anyone else
wish to speak under
uh councilor keen on item seven
any other speakers
I have no apologies for absence this
evening
an item three is minutes of the previous
meeting to approve the summary of
recommendations the decision of the
cabinet meeting held on the 26th of
January 2023 a copy is attached to the
agenda pack I propose we approve the me
the minutes do I have a secondary
councilor Bob bayford do members agree
item four is minutes of the
extraordinary meeting to approve the
summary of recommendations and decisions
of the extraordinary cabinet meeting
held on the 2nd of March 2023 the copy
is also attached to this another to the
supplementary agenda pack I propose we
approve the minutes do I have a second
day counselor Bob bayford two members
agree
item five corporate performance Quarter
Two
2022-23 an item that I will introduce
Performance Management is a key part of
the corporate governance process and
adds value by helping to ensure
accountability of the performance of the
council services against the corporate
objectives
this helps to encourage enhanced
accountability and continue Improvement
continuous Improvement
this report sets out as part of the
council's corporate performance process
39 key performance indicators which are
monitored to provide an indication of
how the council is performing
they do not look at every aspect of the
council services and the data of the
council collects but provides an
overview of the progress against the
council's key corporate priorities
the data for most of the corporate
indicators is now available to view on
our website at any time
it has been agreed that a six-monthy
report of the council's corporate
performance will be shared with the
overview and scrutiny panel and the
cabinet to provide an opportunity to
more closely review the direction of
travel of our key service areas
this will allow sufficient time for
actions and issues to be resolved
between committee meetings and as the
data for the corporate performance
indicators is now available to view on
the website at any time
the report represents this evening this
evening identifies the data as at the
end of quarter two July to September
the data is captured within a new format
to provide the public with a clear and
easy to access information on how key
services are performing
detail graphs also included to give a
wider view of the direction of travel
for each indicator
my thanks go to the overview and
scrutiny panel for their engagement and
feedback surrounding this report at
their meeting
in February the intention is to return
to the overview and scrutiny panel after
the election setting out the position as
at the end of quarter four
I asked the cabinet to note the report
speaking under 20.1
I have counselor
what type
thank you leader
in relation to housing there areas of
concern but these have been well
discussed across many previous meetings
as an ongoing area of concern the
increase in the number of households in
temporary accommodation from 115 in June
2021 to 195 I believe reflects the
external pressures residents are facing
and property inflation rather than
housing performance
this will hopefully be addressed by
further growth of our housing portfolio
but in terms of empty properties brought
back into use there does seem to have
been a drop recently down from 45 to 35.
I'm not certain whether this links to a
monitoring change or is simply a general
decrease
if the letter I was wondering whether it
might be useful to advertise the work of
no use empty more so that homeowners are
aware of the range of help available to
bring properties back into use
on a secondary note I did mention
previously at overview and scrutiny the
pollinators and Open Spaces graph still
seems to be the same as the trees Gruff
so I was wondering if we have the
information relating to pollinators and
open spaces available yet thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead um I'm
going to have to refer this to officers
um no use empty I think
um at Bob Porter and then the pollinator
question
um have we got an officer here to
respond to that one or can I come back
on
Hannah will come back on that one so um
over to you Bob
okay thank you um well I think the
simple answer to that is yes we're happy
to promote no use empty uh locally
through our empty homes officer and
private sector housing team and um on
our website and so on and
just to add a bit more context no use
empty has been a very valuable tool for
the um for our empty property officer to
bring empty properties back into use and
as a district we've benefited more than
any other District in the county from
from that funding and obviously we'll
continue to work with KCC on that that
program
it is a really helpful resource when
properties are struggling with viability
issues to to get them refurbished and
back into use it's probably just worth
adding that we've also got our own
funding available for our own occupiers
that take on empty properties and in the
coming Financial year we've got some
extra resource in in that program which
we'll want to promote as well
I just I was hoping to be able to get to
the database quickly enough to be able
to answer it which I haven't been able
to I'm very sorry we have got the raw
data so we will be able to produce the
graph and we can make sure that that's
added to the website and we can share it
around with counselors as well and my
apologies for not correcting that
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on the percentage of properties where um
bins have been collected successfully
um on the graph there the figure of 99.7
which of course is an incredibly good
figure appears five times but it doesn't
appear on the same point on the graph
I wonder why that was
now the sort of goes up and down it's
the same figure so just find the place
on here for the report
have you got it on your screen
it's page 33 of the of the report number
19.
okay
I just wondered why it appeared like
that but there's a there's a follow-up
to that though as well in that I've seen
figures elsewhere
um relating to the number of bins missed
and that's year on year shows a hell of
an improvement and something like a 60
Improvement but that graph wouldn't
appear to bear that out hmm
I'm guessing but this is a guess
councilor bayford the figure is rounded
up
so halfway between halfway between 99.6
and 99.8
um the the graph hovers around and goes
up and down and roller coasters in the
Dreamland sort of way around 99.7
I think the officers who prepared it
just haven't put
99.72 or 99.73 or whatever that I reckon
I'm not sure about your second question
which is why it doesn't reflect the
Improvement although there is a
significant improvement from
towards the end of the graph but it
hasn't got back up to where we were so I
agree I'm not sure why
I just want to prove I'd ready
[Music]
um could obviously I I think that
probably makes sense because you're only
going on a gauge between 99.6 and 99.8
um so the 99.7 would look like the mean
average of that and so I could probably
see why
why it's all showing up as that but if
we want to take it to another decimal
place I think with that that might then
reflect it totally I don't know how
complicated that would be to do but um
what if they've rounded it they would
know it wouldn't they well yes so um or
whether it's just written perhaps the
algorithm is written to um
bit like the housing numbers maybe I
don't know
but now you're not really sure yeah
right okay well um Hannah if we can have
a look at that and then um obviously um
just for the you can always tell the
accountant in a room can't you
um so thank you councilor Byford we'll
have a look at that anyway
so
um
right where was I so um I've moved this
um do I have a second to cancel Saunders
do members agree
apart
moving swiftly on to the next item so
the next item is item six tenant and
leaseholder key performance indicators
for quarter one
2022-23 housing performance report to
introduce councilor bayford Jill bayford
thank you leader overall the tenant
leaseholder service team has maintained
a steady performance in Quarter Two
as in quarter one there are areas that
are still requiring Improvement and are
being worked on by the team
the team is disappointed that the
position of for electrical safety has
not notably improved we have procured an
additional contractor to assist with
this and they started during quarter
three
Mayors have also taken on another
contractor to help meet demand
gas compliance remains at 100 gas course
customer service statistics statistics
have dropped but this is to do with the
low amount of returns skewing figures
rather than performance
the gas contract is coming to an end
this month therefore the return rate of
surveys is something that they will pick
up with the new contractor
our responsive repairs contractor Mia's
continues to perform well even though
customer satisfaction has dropped the
score is still very high at 90 percent
and the quality of workmanship is also
confirmed through a program of post
inspections
a new set of key performance indicators
have been agreed as part of the
extension of the mayor's contract to
March 2025 and sure to help to drive up
performance
the turnaround times on void properties
fell again in Quarter Two Mayors have
employed more subcontractors to provide
additional resources in this area so we
expect to see Improvement of the second
part of the year
finally rent areas also increased during
Quarter Two
which is a reflection of what's been
happening normally
sorry Russian nationally sorry it is
reassuring however that even though
areas increased has been a reduction
when compared to the same period last
year and the year before I moved the
recommendation set out in
thank you Council bayford to speak under
20.1 councilor Whitehead
thank you leader and thank you councilor
bayford
um I'll be very brief I just want to say
thank you for this report and the huge
amount of effort that has gone into
bringing actions up to date since
housing was brought back in house
I know how much effort it has taken from
all involved and significant progress
has been made across an exceptionally
difficult time
I would also like to say that I welcome
the further contract to speed up the
commendable progress on eicrs
thank you Council lighted would you like
to Justice thank you very much for your
comments I which I share thank you
so members this has been moved I have a
seconder
counselor cup
do members agree
I like to share it out of it I'm moving
down for your turn next
so item seven
item seven is the Margate Winter Gardens
update and decision to introduce
councilor Pugh
thank you chair that's what you meant by
my turn then I'm very I am very very
lucky
cabinet last considered the Winter
Gardens uh in September 2022. at that
meeting the cabinet confirmed the
council's commitment to the future of
the Margate Winter Gardens it agreed on
a number of specific actions designed to
prepare for a marketing campaign to
identify a suitable Opera operator or
commercial partner for the future
I remain fully committed to finding a
suitable partner organization that has
the experience and expertise to remodel
refurbish and reopen this important
Heritage venue and provide it with a
long-term sustainable future
since September we have published a
timeline for this work and I'm pleased
to be able to report good progress
against this timetable and the actions
that were agreed in September
we have completed the necessary
structural survey work and this report
provides information about the condition
of the building and the estimated cost
of central works we have also progressed
work to complete detailed survey
drawings of the building and the
searches and studies needed to inform
decisions about the future
following an open tender process we have
appointed specialist Consultants
counterculture partnership LLP to
complete a review of thanet's evening
and nighttime economy with a focus on
the role of the Winter Gardens
work to complete this study has begun
with a focus on Research to consider the
food and beverage cultural and
accommodation offers conference and
exhibition spaces and other venue
opportunities in thanet this work will
be used to inform the marketing campaign
and the identification of an operator or
commercial partner
during December 2022 and January 2023 we
ran a public engagement exercise using
the council's your voice valet platform
during this time there were 167
participants and 130 questions posted
demonstrating the strength of public
feeling about the Winter Gardens in the
area
we will use this feedback to update the
frequently asked questions on the
council's Margate Town deal web pages
the next stage in this critical project
is the appointment of a specialist agent
to support the council with a
professional marketing campaign and with
the evaluations of proposals from
potential operators of commercial
partners
this report recommends a procurement
process to identify a suitable special
specialist agent excuse me and provides
information about the scope of this work
it recommends a further report to the
cabinet once this works completed I
therefore move the following
recommendations as set out in the report
one especially marketing agency is
appointed as set out in section four two
the director of place in consultation
with the cabinet member for economic
development approves the marketing
particulars for the Winter Gardens and
the evaluation Matrix to be used to
assess um operator and or JV submissions
and three a further report to be
considered my cabinet following the
completion of the marketing and
evaluation exercise setting out detailed
proposals thank you
thank you councilor Pugh
um first to speak under 20.1 councilor
Duckworth
thank you Lita and thank you councilor
Pugh
so um I've been looking at the
evaluation form and I'm wondering if
there's an expectation the potential
operators will be supported by Grant
monies from various funding bodies which
could include the Arts Council
I say this because under the economic
impact section mention is made of
volunteering opportunities volunteers
can of course form part of any matched
funding in kind necessary for Grants
applications
with the Arts Council focusing on areas
outside London in recent times surely
Theater concert hall and events
operators are in a good position to
apply for funding for Margate this
should mean that we don't need to widen
the scope to include Leisure and tourism
operators who may have no interest in
maintaining the traditional uses of the
Winter Gardens
thank you um Council Duckworth councilor
pew
thank you Chan thank you councilor
duckler for your question
um I will refer to our director of
regeneration in a second but I think
it's important that and I completely
take your point with Arts Council
funding and and all of that I think at
this stage it's important that we don't
try and restrict
um any possible operators that want to
come to Winter Gardens what I can say is
that particularly throughout all of this
process special consideration will be
given to any suitable bids that come
forward in relation to how they may want
to potentially change the character of
the building or anything like that I was
in the Winter Gardens on Friday
um showing around Lord Parkinson who is
parliamentary under Secretary of State
for Arts and Heritage
um and he really appreciated the unique
character of the building and I don't
think for one minute that anyone at this
council is potentially going to support
a bid where they're just going to
completely tear everything out and and
start again but I think it's about at
the moment it's important that we don't
try and restrict any kind of possible
options and we see what really comes to
the table but I will defer to our
director of regeneration or our director
of place
um because they may be able to
actually say that I've just spoken
absolutely rubbish and and all of that's
untrue maybe not
so the um scoring criteria
two example of the things that might be
considered when we're scoring
organizations that put themselves
forward and we've had a very similar
conversation about the Arts Council and
have made links within the organization
to think about what those opportunities
might be as as companies are coming out
of London and what's the scale and one
of the things that the Consultants that
are working on the evening and nighttime
economy review one of their roles is to
think about what it what are the
opportunities and speak to the sector
and understand that kind of interest and
some of that's already started which is
really exciting and and hopeful so I
think those there's lots of
opportunities around that I think the
point about grant funding is a well-made
one it will be
um it will have to be considered in
terms of the type of organization that
comes forward and obviously there is
significant investment that's needed and
it will be a way of it could be a way
unlocking some investment but it does
depend on that nature of private public
kind of third sector voluntary
organization so all of that as councilor
Pugh said will be picked up through that
process
um to understand what type of
organization will be interested and and
therefore whether grant funding is
something that could be looked for
okay are you um did you want to add
anything more for you um well thank you
thank you thank you
um I don't think I can only think more
in terms of detail um from what Louise
has already said but just to reinforce
that the the the the report has been put
together specifically in the way it has
to enable us to have a see a broad range
of options come forward and and then for
the for Council and specifically cabinet
to look at those options and and agree
the final detail and at this stage I
think we want to keep those options you
know as open as we can to see what sort
of organizations come forward and and
bring bring proposals
and actually you know we might be
surprised we might see some really
exciting proposals come forward that we
hadn't anticipated so you know trying to
prejudge that at this stage just feels a
bit too early
yes I think that's that's the um the aim
really is to have as much interest and
as wider spec as we can and then
obviously then
can be narrowed down when we get nearer
the time
um next to speak under 20.1 um councilor
Whitehead
thank you leader
I do understand very clearly the
complexities of the issues surrounding
the Winter Gardens
I understand how difficult it is to
maintain large public structures in a
national environment of continuing
underfunding and I also understand how
challenging it can be having to rely on
external organizations to manage and
preserve assets
in The Current financial climate this is
even more challenging
extraordinary rises in energy costs
increased costs in terms of materials
for construction and refurbishment make
this project with likely costs of over 6
million a considerable challenge for any
external partner
but the extent of that challenge and the
nature of the financial Market shouldn't
to my mind mean that we should have to
lose overall control of such a
significant asset
I am aware that a sale will be seen to
be easier to manage than Elise in terms
of the likelihood of investment
but I also believe it is important to
remember that if this is arguably our
most significant Community Asset and
that our rights to determine usage and
guarantee maintenance disappear at the
moment the building is sold
across planet we are often faced with
the realities of this approach
in Ramsgate we are struggling with the
maintenance of our seafront pathway due
to the disposal of the old Westcliff
Hall
in Margate we risk what is effectively
the jewel in our Crown in terms of
architecture and social and Community
potential furling and falling into
further disrespect disrepair as Once
Sold the future of the Winter Gardens is
out of our hands
I will acknowledge that I personally
believe that in-house service and
development is the way forward for
public services a sensible investment
creates income and better monitoring
control
and although I recognize the financial
challenges I still do not believe that
the only possible route here is external
development
but if cabinet are following that route
I request that the significance of a
Lease Only basis is considered
the loss of public buildings and
services is a Hallmark of current
underfunding
as depressing as it is to say it's not
unique to Bennett and maintaining public
buildings is a constant fight for nearly
all local authorities
but if we allow the current political
and financial environment to remove all
of our control from what our public
assets I believe we may do a great
disservice to residents
a full repairing lease with Clauses
relating to structural and social
performance allows a far to Greater
degree of control and benefit to the
community than sale
and although we are always swimming
against the tide in terms of funding
allowing Finance to dictate social good
cannot be what we were able to reduce to
as a council
I ask that a full repairing lease linked
to community and material performance be
seriously considered in preference to
sale due to the nature of the Winter
Gardens
the Winter Gardens has always been a
Community Asset I attended prize giving
for my school there for almost all of my
education took part in concerts and in
community Productions
this youth is important and if disposal
is chosen this importance not only needs
to be made explicit within the scoring
Matrix with a guaranteed retention of
community use but also needs to be
explicit within any lease Arrangements
we have lost huge amounts of community
provision in terms of maintained
buildings over the last decade and those
of us who follow National politics are
aware of why
but we can follow a different path
locally
and I asked cabinet to consider not only
the positives of inward investment for
our community and for our area as a
whole but also the benefits of lease
rather than sale if they do decide that
disposal is the way forward
thank you
Council Whitehead I mean I I would add
that on 4.4 sorry to um
you know it's your response counselor
Pew but we do make is very clear in the
report that um
that it is potential buyers operators
and then we also go on to talk about
sale lease or operating agreement so at
this point there is absolutely no
um preference on to how or who or why it
will be chosen it's that we're not at
that point yet so I don't think it's um
something that should be assumed that
it's an automatic sale because that
every auction is being is is going to be
visited so um I think that's important
to make that point but uh councilor Pew
um sorry just to clarify no I wasn't
saying that sale is assumed or is
definitely going to happen I was simply
asking least to be considered in
preference to fail thank you
thank you um councilor Whitehead for
your um
for sharing your views
um
and and your preferences I think it's
incredibly important at this stage that
we don't overly as I said to encountered
in response to cancer Duckworth it's
important at this stage that we don't
try and restrict uh what we look into at
the moment as we all I think we can all
agree that winter cars is incredibly
treasured and loved uh building within
our area I've got very fond memories as
you have of going there for my school
um award ceremonies and and charity
events and performances and everything
like that and I don't think there is
anyone in thanet that hasn't got a
memory of going there for for something
so I think it's incredibly important
that we get this right and I think
that's why it's important that we don't
try and restrict it right now to whether
it should be a sale or a lease or
anything like that I think it's
important that we courage
as many suitable operators to come
forward with their ideas and then we can
then across all of them we can assess
them all against the Matrix against the
criteria to find the best possible
future for the Winter Gardens because
that is the that is the the objective of
this
um
it's interesting you say about your
concerns about the sale of the Winter
Gardens and I'm not saying that that's
my preferred preference I don't have a
preferred preference but there is
instances very recent instances where
the council has sold
um very well-loved entertainment venue
the Granville theater is one of them now
that in the space of not even a year of
sale and we went for a very long process
um during the kind of uh publicizing of
that and then the eventual sale you know
the new owners of of the Granville
theater are going through a very
extensive renovation process to bring
that
um up to code and up to speed so they
can reopen I think they're going to
reopen in May which is incredibly
exciting
um I've been there to have a look at the
work I think some of the labor
opposition cabinet have even been there
to have a look at the work as well which
is fantastic
um certainly wouldn't mean that it's
just me that goes around with a hard hat
and the hive is on looking at these
these assets but it's a prime example of
where actually sometimes there are
buildings that are better in hands of
private organizations that want to
invest serious money into them and and
bring them up to a suitable
suitable condition where they can
benefit everyone within the community
I'm not saying that's my preference for
the Winter Gardens but what I mean is an
example of what some places where a sale
of an asset does work and it does work
for the better of all and that's why I
think it's important that at this stage
we shouldn't completely rule that out
thank you councilpie
[Music]
2.1 Council Yates
thank you a leader and thank you Council
Pugh for report
um I'm glad the council is moving ahead
with this agenda item the council's
um hopeful to meet the timeline set out
on the website regarding the venue
um just two questions for me firstly
what is the definition that we're using
when it when it comes to Leisure use it
mentioned in this report
um councilor Duckworth mentioned this
already but I understand
concert space theater space event space
but I'm unsure was being agreed to when
we mentioned Leisure Leisure use tonight
is the council for example
um keeping open the option for a Gold's
Gym Valentine's gym or Laser Quest
coming to Winter Gardens
um I don't think that would be the
appropriate use
for this venue and I think residents
would agree this is a performance space
community and
entertainment space and I think we need
to be very careful when it comes to use
the why we are saying this is a Leisure
use because from my understanding
Leisure use means Leisure Center
swimming pools tennis courts what what
is the definition that we're using in
the report when it comes to the Legends
um second question
as mentioned by Council Whitehead
tonight I think we should be very
specific on the social impact benefit
part of the evaluation form and be clear
but what we mean by Community
Council white has said about prize
giving ceremonies from local schools so
let's mention thanet schools as part of
the community the Margate operating
Society who performed sold out
performances there other community
events such as the the Easter beer and
cider Festival which is hugely popular
and always sold out and benefiting local
breweries so I think
are tied to definition of community
would actually help us when we come to
evaluation of that
forms
so is it possible to make it clear on
the evaluation form thanks
thank you councilor Yates um I'll hand
you over to councilor Pugh for these the
two questions
thank you Chan thank you Council Yates
for your question I'll defer to our
director of regeneration really to
answer uh specific questions that you've
raised but I mean you talk about leisure
activities I think the cider and beer
festival I wouldn't really say that
that's a an entertainment or you know
music as much people may get a bit
excited to dance on the tables surely
that's a bit more you know Leisure and
all that kind of stuff
um and even even tourism as well because
it probably brings people into the area
um but I'll defer to our director of
regeneration and our director of place
as well
thanks I think the use of the word
measure is so that we're not
predetermining what type of activity to
see in there so a music venue is quite
different from a theater and a
performance venue and and some of those
things will
change the way that companies approach
what happens within the theater within
the sorry within the Winter Gardens and
we've had quite a lot of discussion with
specialists around that what are the
things that would make it different if
it was a music venue or if it was a
particularly a theater or a you know
those types of activities so the use of
the word Leisure is so that it is more
broad so that we're not then
predetermining but I think in the as
part of the evening and nighttime
economy review we will have potentially
more defined specifications and vision
around what could happen at the Winter
Gardens Based on data based on
information of who will travel who will
pay money what sort of money people will
pay for what they will pay to see
because what we do need to do whatever
happens at the Winter Gardens is it
needs to be sustainable and it needs to
be able to pay for a listed building on
a seafront so we need to be really
careful that what we do makes help
Safeguard the building for the future so
the evidence
through the evening and nighttime
economy review will help to develop that
vision and Define what that looks like
as we go out to the market go out for
marketing and I think the same sort of
answer with the social value point we
need to understand how that building
could be sustainable in the long term it
needs to be able to pay for the
Investments as a return on investment
from the The Upfront that investment
that will be required to refurbish and
repurpose the building and any
organization would need to be able to
see that unless it was grant funding and
and that's challenging
um but also I think as we said earlier
the
um scoring Matrix is an indicator of
what could be used it's not the final
scoring Matrix and that will come from
engagement with a marketing company
foreign
referring to a
to the heart to the Bible
um Leisure has often been defined as a
quality of experience or as free time so
we can take it from there it is it is an
experience so there we go
next to speak under 20.1 councilor Keane
thank you leader
um obviously thanic residents are Keen
to see progress with the Winter Garden
so it's really good to have this update
and hear what's going on but in
particular the nighttime economy survey
in the report it says it will be
completed in March 23 so I'm interested
to know where we are with that is it
going to be finished by the end of March
and then after that how will it the
findings be shared thank you
thank you councilor Pugh do you have
yeah thank you chair I'm just going to
defer to our director of place and
director of regeneration to answer that
but from what I'm aware of is that
particularly with the entirety of the
program although some things may have
slightly slipped we're still on course
to deliver the entirety of the program
um within the time scales that we've set
out so you know particularly with the
nighttime economy study and everything
even if things do slip slightly uh we're
still on course to deliver all of it
which I think is incredibly encouraging
and great but I'll defer to officers now
the evening nighttime economy is
slightly behind the original timeline
and that largely is due to the
procurement processes so we've been
through an open tendering process to
secure that
um that partner that's quite a lengthy
process so it is slightly behind the
original
um timeline but it we have appointed
them they have started and it is
progressing so we're expecting to be
able to report on that
um during during the Spring
um
we that that report will be available
and you'll be able to see it and we'll
be publishing that so
um it'll be it will be part of the
marketing information as well so um you
know it's all going to be it's all going
to be out there on the council's website
and publicly available
yeah so just to add to that
um we've had a draft of the phase one of
the report which I haven't it only came
through yesterday so I haven't read it
yet
um but that's more about the kind of
data Gathering the desktop research
research about the sector and
um what opportunities are out there what
other places are doing that kind of
stuff there'll be some case study
information in there as well and then we
have a couple of quite small round table
discussions and we're going to do some
surveys out to community organizations
and to our
um kind of visitor and tourism database
that we've got and and that can be
shared to other businesses within that
sector so some specific questions
there's just been a bit of to and fro in
terms of making sure we've got the right
kinds of questions in there so all of
that information will then help to feed
in and then we'll be doing some more
open engagement with communities and
some of that's just about timing and
thinking about Easter holidays so it is
delayed it's not going to be completed
by the end of March
um obviously due to some of the things
that Bob said but
um quite a lot of work is underway and
we've got the drawings that we needed so
the architect who's part of the
commission can start to look at what's
the art of the possible in terms of the
building and we're continuing to do some
more surveys so we've got like the
ordinance surveys making sure there's no
unexploded devices in the grounds and
various other things like that and
thinking about
um
the but more broadly around the garden
so that we can make sure that we've got
the right information so that when we go
to the market actually we've got a full
pack of information that will help with
those people that are interested in and
hopefully it'll help encourage people
with you know more interest to come
forward because they've got a lot of
details there
thank you
um
so it has been moved by councilor Pugh
do I have a second councilor Jill
bayford do members agree
I think that concludes our business for
this evening
the meeting is closed declare the
meeting closed at
1939 chance thank you members and
members of the public and enjoy the rest
of your evening and officers thank you